il n'y a plus que des piétons sur le
pont simon bolivar le bond le plus
fréquenté entre le venezuela et la
colombie plus d'autos le commerce et la
contrebande réduits au minimum
des contrôles de plus en plus strictes
une ambiance de guerre froide
cinquante mille vénézuélien traverse le
pont vers la colombie tous les jours
5000 d'entre eux ne reviendront plus ce
sont ceux qui ont des bagages balises ou
sac à dos ses valets venezuela
il quitte le chômage une hyper inflation
de près d'un million pour cent la misère
la faim les pénuries de vivres et de
médicaments
[Rires]
beaucoup d'entre eux font la queue une
ou deux fois par jour à la casse à des
paso de la divine providence où ils
reçoivent des repas comme en allemagne
le padre david gère les opérations avec
une précision presque militaire neuf
cents volontaires et employés des ong
internationales préparent des repas
complets de très bonne qualité qui pour
des vénézuéliens sont devenus
impossibles à obtenir la base de données
il gagne 3 dollars par mois chez eux ici
on leur sert à vos pas complet qui vaut
3 $ pour combien de personnes chaque
jour
quatre mille personnes et quatre nuits
tous les jours sauf le dimanche
derrière chacun des visages de chaque
famille chaque personne se cache un
drame
parfois une tragi cros et louise patch
anneau est en route pour le pérou il
était chirurgien à l'hôpital
universitaire clinique de caracas en
2015 ses collègues et lui sont remplacés
par des médecins communautaires et des
chirurgiens cubain par le gouvernement
maduro mais comme on est à lyon elle
allait de la femme au sahara où le
cinéma l'aude en novembre sa fille est
atteinte d'un cancer par se faire
soigner au pays où faute de traitement
hier pour lui annonce la mort de sa
fille il ya quand même eu lieu
[Musique]
tels des ongles à yahoo doit s'occuper
des funérailles il compte rester au
pérou définitivement la question de
retourner au venezuela
son épouse est enceinte avant de passer
les frontières des bandits vénézuélien
lors ont tout volé argent et papiers ils
vont chercher de l'aide auprès des ong
cette frontière a toujours été très
ouverte mais autrefois il n'y a pas si
longtemps ce sont les colombiens qui
allait se réfugier au venezuela pour
fuir la violence de la guérilla des
paramilitaires et aussi pour trouver du
travail parce que le venezuela était le
pays le plus riche d'amérique du sud
avec son pétrole
maintenant celle inverse qui se produit
et on assiste à une crise migratoire
sans précédent en amérique la colombie à
son tour rend service mais c'est un
poids énorme chaque mois 100 mille
vénézuélien débarque et quasi 6000
personnes à s'ancrer dans cent mille
personnes c'est l'équivalent d'une bonne
ville moyenne ce qui vient avec plus de
criminalité concurrence déloyale dans le
commerce
et depuis l'an dernier on parle d'un
phénomène qui s'appelle sénat mais sans
trop de violences juste ici les
autorités de los pas permis pour éviter
de trop fortes concentrations
les migrants doivent quitter la région
et ils le font souvent à pied
cette famille a quitté caracas et 120
vers calais déjà en auto leur ont donné
de la nourriture
il s'apprête à repartir ils sont mal
équipés
cali est à plus de 900 km un millier de
personnes prennent la route ainsi tous
les jours à cette heure halte il laisse
des messages sur des billets de banque
qui ne valent plus rien des messages de
foi et d'espoir on veut aussi laisser la
trace de son passage
certains messages s'en prennent au
président nicholas mode de l'eau celui
ci dit notre pays a été détruit grâce à
la révolution de maduro et ses voleurs
corrompus et ses misérables militaire un
jour ils vont payer
puis ils reprennent la route vers les
montagnes ils ne le savent peut-être pas
mais là haut ils auront froid